et ce matin son défi c'est d'essayer de
nous faire prendre le large en
retrouvant la nature quel est votre
secret Tiphaine et bien je vous ai
trouvé plein de livres qui parlent de
vacances au vert mais vous savez pour
certains enfants cette perspective n'est
pas très enthousiasmante et c'est le cas
du héros de ce livre Game Over attention
à pas Game Over c'est un livre de Damian
et Esteban Hernandez publié chez bambou
édition alors je vous explique le héros
Daniel doit partir en vacances chez ses
grands-parents à la montagne mais lui
c'est un enfant de la vie là alors sans
wifi et sans jeux vidéo cette
perspective est horrible et ses
grands-parents le savent alors ils lui
ont prévu un programme génial avec
énormément d'activités cueillettes
randonnée vélo et chaque activité
débloquera un palier comme dans un jeu
vidéo tout cela grâce à la complicité
d'une jeune montagnarde nommée Selva et
qui a le même âge que lui alors c'est
une bande dessinée vraiment très
enthousiasmante pleine de fantaisie qui
prône bien vous l'aurez compris la
déconnexion le retour à la nature et qui
plaira aux enfants à partir de 8 ans je
vous la conseille moi-même je me suis
beaucoup amusée c'est vraiment très très
drôle et puis ça donnera plein d'idées
aux parents et aux grands-parents si
jamais vous êtes en manque d'inspiration
et bien n'hésitez pas commencez par lire
la BD et puis vous pourrez proposer
plein d'activités aux enfants évidemment
toute ressemblance avec des faits
existants ou ayant existé n'est pas
fortuite forcément vous l'aurez compris
j'ai cru vous entendre Jérémie quand
elle a parlé de de wifi d'écran
vous-même vous avez des enfants c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile de les
déconnecter pas facile de déconnecter
mais moi j'ai avantage de vivre à la
campagne donc ils aiment aussi faire du
cerf-volant du vélo et même s'amuser
dans le jardin donc mais c'est vrai que
les écrans pressions qu'ils ont été
greffés avec en fait c'est
impressionnant puis s'occuper de vos
chiens et de la porter que vient d'avoir
votre chien quand même bon
allez on reste en pleine nature même si
c'est pas forcément évident c'est ce
qu'on va découvrir et c'est ce que va
découvrir aussi what what qui est une
fée des villes à des dedans on fait des
villes vous connaissez des villes vous
non je connais la fais pas chier le
matin j'ai souvent celle-là quand on
m'embête un petit peu et parfois ça peut
arriver mais bon cette fiche la
connaissais pas c'est une fée des villes
obligée de partir vivre loin de chez
elle mais qui est donc cette fée
dites-moi Tiphaine
fait c'est ça un Pascal un être avec des
ailes qui brillent qui adore la nature
et qui parle aux animaux et bien pas du
tout l'héroïne de cazena William et
jacquemer les les auteurs phares de
bambou c'est une fée du bitume qui
déteste la nature et qui aime la
pollution et les magasins mais un jour
elle perd ses ailes et elle se retrouve
projetée dans la forêt à devoir et
bienvenue en aide au peuple enchanté
avec un troll des égouts oui ça donne
tout de suite une idée de l'univers
alors évidemment c'est très farfelu
c'est assez drôle c'est plein de
rebondissements dans cette BD bien les
faits sont mal élevés et impertinentes
et les enfants sont des sales gosses
donc ça plaira aux adolescents autant
vous le dire les deux tomes sont déjà
sortis donc l'histoire est bouclée c'est
pas mal pour l'été ça permet d'emmener
ça dans sa valise de passer du bon temps
et évidemment vous vous en doutez le
message et pour la protection de
l'environnement parce que que ferait une
fée des villes sans fait des champs
et les sales gosses
bon nous sommes nombreux à vouloir aller
aussi au calme dans la verdure au
silence y compris aussi nos propres
enfants parfois qui ont besoin de de se
déconnecter vous lisez fort justement
Jérémy mais ça tombe bien parce que là
vous avez un livre qui est publié aux
éditions La Joie de lire ça veut tout
dire oui alors vous le voyez déjà la
couverture donne tout de suite
GAB
Riel parce que il a la tête farcie un
farci de géo de maths de français farci
décrites ses camarades il les aime bien
bien sûr mais au bout d'un moment ça
suffit quand il sort de l'école même les
bruits de la ville le perturbe alors lui
il a envie de partir de s'enfuir vers la
campagne vers et bien les paysages
proposés par Maëlys d'offrey et Juliette
Lagrange c'est joli aquarelles qui nous
emmènent tout de suite dans un autre
univers et il parle vendredi soir
rejoindre son grand-père rejoindre et
bien les bruits de la campagne rejoint
de ses grands arbres et regarder les
étoiles c'est un très bel album pour les
enfants à partir de 5 ans qui proposent
et bien de prendre le temps de se
reconnecter à la nature c'est un bel
album pour les vacances mais pas
seulement voilà pour le week-end et puis
pour prendre du bon temps allez un
dernier album en 30 secondes en guise de
carnet de bord pour les vacances c'est
votre mission Tiphaine et oui et bien je
vous propose de construire une cabane
vous aviez oublié que ça existait mais
c'est un plaisir simple à partager avec
ses parents ses grands-parents
ressortaient les marteaux les clous les
branches et puis aller construire une
cabane c'est un album grand format de
Guillaume Gairaut et Alfred publié à La
Martinière Jeunesse et puis évidemment
en fait faire du jardinage profitez-en
mettez les mains dans la terre vous
verrez ça fera rêver les enfants ce sera
leur univers leur repère un bon moyen de
s'autonomiser et si vous ne pouvez pas
faire une cabane à l'extérieur et bien
la tente dans le salon ça marche aussi
avec un bel album pour développer son
imagination j'adore j'adore j'adore
super ça doit être un joyeux BIM ce chez
vous la tente dans le salon avec les
enfants
ça sent le vécu très très bien en tout
cas bravo et merci à la sélection livre
à partager ensemble régulièrement sur
France 3 sur les réseaux sociaux je sais
que vous postez régulièrement aussi ces
petits moments que nous partageons on
partagera d'autres moments dès la
rentrée avec un nouveau cartable et
jolie surprise à l'intérieur je vous
fais confiance Tiphaine